welcome to this video playing raw alex
weprin Sofia he was a very regular play
on the ICC but hasn't played much lately
and okay let's see what he's doing in
this game but I can tell you that he's
playing like a real mad man sometimes
it's so wild stuff might happen ok let's
see something at kings game but yeah
here we go the Kings gambit um maybe
let's fight fire with fire playing the
enolate counter gambit and see what he's
doing against that going for for some
some funny and complications Knight
takes d5 or night xe5 Knight f6 funny
stuff f5 is not as bad as it looks I
mean it looks really crazy but it is in
fact in fact playable I'm wondering
about Bishop c4 him can I go d5 after
that or can you take on d5 ok it's not
it's not going for that um Bishop c5 may
be on nite nite deform or is this crazy
moving the night again it probably is
crazy right hmm maybe just Bishop c5
cannot be bad I think to prevent
castling and maybe he can take on your
form just that I think of it 94 94 Queen
h5 this kind of stuff can can happen
really wow ID floor really
94 Quincy for but I have also Queenie
seven so I really have a hard time to
believe that but as i announced it is
getting crazy Queenie 7 now if I take
there is meeting me threatening made on
f7 so i probably have to do this but he
still cannot castle and I'm threatening
to just win with c6 okay before I can
take here and take on before at least at
least and I still have the c6 Fred my
eyes is just trying to attack play as
crazy as possible and and try to confuse
me but black is simply winning here very
sure about it but still it is a very
very crazy position I'm just threatening
c6 basically c65 and resins I'm not sure
that he can do much about it Bishop e3
maybe I still will place is six no
matter what ok he's retreating it
voluntarily let's just prepare d5 that's
probably right in any case d5 breaks
this important diagonal and also
prevents
a pass Bishop g4 just d5 t5 queen bee
three and then I can go to d3 it's not
not a problem I believe 93 if it takes
takes a threatened Bishop g4 winning I
wonder hmm 93 m on 93 if it takes it
this Bishop g4 yeah this is Sir this is
a very very big threat
I'm threatening night f2 as well so okay
didn't really see that one coming not
good
mmm how to play it now of course I can
always get get the the rook in the other
corner but still okay I probably okay I
can also play the check on g4 but does
not lead to much so i probably need to
do that check Bishop g7 on King taking
move may be here to get so that i can do
to g6 ever ones Wow ship and i really
wonder is there some way to just play
form for that tech here or do i need to
get the rook
do I need to get the rook or is that
something better yeah I should probably
probably take it so what is this have a
piece up at the moment but it's a total
mess and you can take the five
night d 5 is what is best Queen e6 may
be setting up this pin I can also take
it I but maybe Queenie 6m so Knight f6 I
take v3 GF and i don't know i mean what
what what a crazy position and he's very
reliable to play on time in any position
so i should be I should try to be quick
didn't see that one not good time
morning oh what a nightmare night check
this is really really super crazy check
from a position where I was certainly
completely winning he sort of he soldier
get out of this I mean no that's just
not right yeah I threatening pusher
before of course okay
giant Bishop f5 only have 20 seconds
left I just got Quinn Quinn
I'm okay again but can almost play this
as a pre move check check okay
and this is getting getting close check
check check game yeah just two seconds
more and I would have still won this
game of course he should never ever
reach move 20 or whatever widest totally
lost here but what what a mess what a
complete mess before him as I told you
he is a madman c 6 a-3 and yeah i just
did not see night xe6 beforehand after
b5 he can simply resign him and this is
not exactly difficult to see what I was
just thinking okay I play this and I go
here and he gives up but now you no no
no I see my [ __ ] my mistake I should
have played Bishop g4 first ah this is
this is in fact quite easy check I
provide that why don't I play Bishop g4
and taking on a eight having sometimes I
think I really need to need a brain
check I mean jack ok this might win as
well but this is this is very very very
easy just getting this back and I mean
the promise white is playing without all
those pieces here I just have a deadly
attack now yeah just to give you an eval
compass on minus 8y a minus eight ok
well this is just minus four but of
course Green is six ah how can I miss f5
ok it's the wind sang there should be
six wins
I decided to take it should be six wins
okay Joe White Queen does not have many
squares yeah I mean I'm still a piece up
here so there's really not not a big
surprise that I should win but yeah I
went here and I really have managed to
screw this up Bishop a 6 ok and you see
that one check here ya hear Quincy three
now was winning attacking c5 and 37 yeah
it was just a total I mess this game and
now Luke fa twins immediately ok but I
had 18 seconds others also wins okay I
had seen I had seen this and yet it does
win him so Chan and Tre I ok really
really quick player can can can win yay
I ok I made some stupid primos like this
for example of course you should go here
and I also should take on g3 with the
rook later to get the Queen at the end
to mate so much quicker Wow ok thanks
for watching